Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. Now, last week I went on a quest.
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告连播、剧集抢先听，并成为我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告连播以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，只需轻点几下即可在应用内订阅。你好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。话说上周，我踏上了一场探索之旅。
It had long been an ambition of mine to visit the grave of J.R.R. Tolkien, author of The Hobbit and Lord of the Rings. And with this new Amazon series coming out, I thought, what better time? So I set off from my home, left my beloved home behind. There was a tube strike, so I had to walk miles and miles and miles. Then I had to get on a train. It was very crowded. I had to stand the whole way. Then Tolkien's grave is the north of Oxford, so I had to walk all the way up there. I was about a mile away from the grave, and by now the burden of my quest was feeling very, very heavy on me. And I could well have abandoned it altogether, were it not for the fact that about a mile
拜访《霍比特人》和《指环王》的作者 J.R.R. 托尔金的墓地，长久以来一直是我的一个愿望。随着亚马逊这部新剧的上映，我想，还有什么比这更好的时机呢？于是我从家里出发，告别了我心爱的家。当时地铁在罢工，所以我不得不走了好几英里又好几英里。接着我不得不去坐火车。人非常多。我一路站到了终点。托尔金的墓在牛津的北部，所以我不得不一路走过去。离墓地大概还有一英里远的时候，此时我感到此行的负担非常非常沉重。要不是因为大约在一英里外
from Tolkien's grave, I met up with my loyal retainer, a simple countryman of humble yeoman stock, Dominic Gamgee Sandbrook. And Dominic, in my hour of need, I needed the solid yeoman strength that only you could provide. And what was your response to my suggestion that we go and visit Tolkien's grave? I suggested we went for steak and chips. You did? And then after we'd had it, after we'd had lunch, you had a car. So you could have taken me there in your car.
我遇到了我的忠实随从，一个出身卑微的乡下农夫，多米尼克·加姆吉·桑德布鲁克，我可能早就彻底放弃了。多米尼克，在我需要帮助的时候，我需要那种只有你才能提供的坚定农夫力量。对于我提出去拜访托尔金墓的建议，你的反应是什么？我建议我们去吃牛排和薯条。你确实这么说了？然后我们吃完后，在吃过午饭之后，你有一辆车。所以你本可以用你的车带我去那里的。
And did you do it? No, no, I didn't. But I mean, to be fair, Tom, we had to have our photos taken. I think it's Mr. Tom, actually. Your bodyguard? No, his guard. So anyway, so we met up in Oxford last week. And obviously, Oxford is a place that is hallowed by the memory of J.R.R. Tolkien,
那你照做了吗？没有，没有，我没有。但我的意思是，公平地说，汤姆，我们得拍照。我觉得其实是汤姆先生。你的保镖？不，他的保镖。总之，上周我们在牛津碰面了。显然，牛津是一个被 J.R.R. 托尔金的记忆所神圣化的地标，
who is the subject of today's episode, prompted by the fact that, as I said previously, that Amazon are doing this. Well, it's a kind of prequel, isn't it, to Lord of the Rings? Yes, that's right. And The Hobbit and all that kind of stuff. But, Dominic, I think before we tuck into Tolkien and all that kind of stuff, we should absolutely recognize the fact that there are lots of people out there who've never read Tolkien. And it's not just that they haven't
这也是我们今天这期节目的主题，正如我之前所说，这是由亚马逊正在制作的这部剧引发的。嗯，这算是《指环王》的前传，对吧？是的，没错。《霍比特人》和所有这些类似的东西。但是，多米尼克，我认为在我们深入探讨托尔金以及所有这些内容之前，我们绝对应该承认这样一个事实：外面有很多人从没读过托尔金。而且不只是他们没
read Tolkien, they militantly don't want to read Tolkien. He despises everything about it, the dragons, the elves, all that kind of stuff. So just to give some obvious examples, we had Judith Downey. I have not read the books. I did see film number one in my role as grandmother. My question is, can you bring to bear your customary wit and wisdom? Charming, Judith. Thank you for that. That's nice. Sufficient to maintain my interest for the interminable number of episodes you will inevitably produce. And we had Richard H. I have never read any Tolkien. Is he really that significant? And if so, why? Domin Tolkien. Is he really that significant? And if so, why,
读过托尔金，他们是坚决不想读托尔金。他鄙视关于它的一切，龙、精灵，所有这些乱七八糟的东西。为了举几个显而易见的例子，我们有朱迪·唐尼。我没有读过这些书。作为祖母，我确实看过第一部电影。我的问题是，你能展现出你惯常的机智和智慧吗？迷人啊，朱迪。谢谢你。这很好。足以让我对你们不可避免会制作的无数集节目保持兴趣。我们还有理查德·H。我从来没读过任何托尔金的书。他真的那么重要吗？如果是的话，为什么？多米尼克·托尔金。他真的那么重要吗？如果是的话，为什么，
Dominic, is he really that significant? Yes. So this is a history podcast. And so let's say right at the beginning, it's not a sort of Tolkien, I mean, though Tom and I may prove to be Tolkien enthusiasts, may reveal ourselves to be Tolkien enthusiasts, it's not a Tolkien enthusiast podcast. And it's absolutely aimed at people who love the books, but also people who have no intention of ever reading a single word. And the reason, the justification really, Tom, is that Tolkien is a significant historical figure. I think for two reasons. One, just very starkly, his book, The Lord of the Rings is the single best-selling english language book
多米尼克，他真的那么重要吗？是的。所以这是一个历史播客。让我们在一开始就说明，这并不是那种托尔金——我的意思是，尽管汤姆和我可能会被证明是托尔金狂热粉，可能会展现出我们是托尔金狂热粉，但这并不是一个专为托尔金狂热粉准备的播客。它绝对是面向那些热爱这些书的人，同时也面向那些压根没打算读过哪怕一个字的人。其原因，或者说真正的理由，汤姆，在于托尔金是一个重要的历史人物。我认为原因有二。第一，非常直截了当地说，他的书《指环王》是20世纪单本销量最好的英文书，
of the 20th century and therefore presumably i mean certainly probably the world in the world yeah so i think probably the world i think there might be some chinese contenders um but certainly in the west uh the lord of the rings stands alone really as the by far the most successful book probably the most influential if you went into the any bookshop in Britain, America, Australia, you could take out probably scores, if not hundreds of books that have been very, very clearly directly influenced by Tolkien. And so the question is, why has it been so successful? Exactly. So the question is, why so successful? But also, I think the second reason why it's interesting is that Tolkien, I mean, he's obviously a historical figure.
因此据推测——当然可能也是世界上——在世界上，是的——所以我想可能是在世界上，我认为可能会有一些中国的竞争者，嗯，但当然在西方，嗯，《指环王》确实独树一帜，可以说是迄今为止最成功的书，可能也是最具影响力的书。如果你走进英国、美国、澳大利亚的任何一家书店，你可能会挑出几十本，甚至上百本受过托尔金非常非常明显直接影响的书。所以问题是，为什么它会如此成功？没错。所以问题是，为什么这么成功？但同时，我认为第二个有趣的原因是，托尔金，我的意思是，他显然是一个历史人物。
He's somebody who was born in the 1890s, came of age just before the First World War, fought in the First World War at the Battle of the Somme. And after that, had actually a pretty quiet life, as we'll go on to discuss. But his books are a brilliant window, I think, into understanding the preoccupations and anxieties of going from the late Victorian period through to the Cold War. So anxieties about war, about technology, about industrialization, about the changes to the landscape. So they're seen as prefiguring the environmental movement, for example. I mean, there's an awful lot there. There are a lot of threads to unpick. And all of that without really, we don't need to talk about, we don't actually need to talk about a single elf. If you're an elpaphobe, don't worry.
他生于1890年代，在第一次世界大战前夕成年，并在第一次世界大战的索姆河战役中作战。在那之后，正如我们接下来要讨论的，他的生活其实相当平静。但我认为，他的书是一扇极好的窗户，能帮助我们理解从维多利亚时代晚期一直到冷战时期人们的关注点和焦虑。比如对战争、对技术、对工业化、对地貌变化的焦虑。所以它们被视为预示了后来的环保运动，等等。我的意思是，里面有非常多的内容。有很多线索需要去解开。所有这些甚至都不需要我们去讨论——我们其实根本不需要讨论哪怕一个精灵。如果你有精灵恐惧症，别担心。
I think we will talk about elves because I would say there's a third reason why Tolkien is a valid and interesting subject to study. And that is quite aside from the fact that he's a kind of colossal British cultural icon. So we've already done, we've done the Beatles, we've done Ian Fleming, we've done Agatha Christie, we've done George Orwell. All of you. Sherlock Holmes. Sherlock Holmes. So they are all massive British cultural figures that have also had a global resonance. But Tolkien is far more than any of those. He is a major, major scholar of key aspects of history, specifically the languages of the early Middle Ages, the German languages in particular, but also of the history.
我想我们还是会谈到精灵的，因为我要说，托尔金是一个值得研究的有效且有趣的主题，还有第三个原因。那就是，抛开他是英国庞大文化偶像这一事实不谈——所以我们已经做过了，我们做过披头士乐队，做过伊恩·弗莱明，做过阿加莎·克里斯蒂，做过乔治·奥威尔。你们所有的。福尔摩斯。福尔摩斯。所以他们都是具有全球共鸣的英国巨大文化人物。但托尔金远不止于此。他是历史关键领域的一位重要学者，具体来说是中世纪早期的语言，特别是日耳曼语族，还有历史。
And so his perspective and his views on early medieval language and on the history of that period is also, I think, worth looking at. So I think that's a third reason. Yeah. I mean, just to qualify that a bit, or to amplify it, Tolkien is the single most important person to have ever written about Beowulf. They're kind of, in many ways, one of the great founding documents of English literature and of the English language. Tolkien is the man who basically brought it into the limelight, into the sort of scholarly limelight. So even if he'd never published a word about Middle-earth and all that sort of stuff, he would be remembered by scholars
因此，我认为他对早期中世纪语言以及该时期历史的视角和看法，也非常值得一看。所以我认为这是第三个原因。是的。我的意思是，稍微限定一下，或者说阐发一下，托尔金是所有写过《贝奥武夫》的人当中最重要的一位。在很多方面，它们是英国文学和英语的伟大奠基文献之一。托尔金正是基本上将它带入聚光灯下、带入学术聚光灯下的人。所以，即便他从未发表过哪怕一个关于中德大陆（Middle-earth）和所有这些内容的字，他也会被学者们铭记
as the man who had basically put Beowulf front and centre. So that makes him interesting too, especially when you think the bloke who sort of, as it were, rediscovered Beowulf is also the bloke who fought at the Battle of the Somme. Yeah. I mean, you could, but you could go further and say that certainly in the English speaking world, Tolkien has probably had a greater influence on how the Middle Ages are popularly understood than anyone else in the 20th century. Yeah. I mean, you could draw a line from Walter Scott through Tolkien to Game of Thrones on TV right now. Yeah. So Walter Scott, I would say, would be his only rival as someone
为那个基本上将《贝奥武夫》置于核心地位的人。所以这让他也变得很有趣，特别是当你想到这个某种程度上重新发现了《贝奥武夫》的家伙，同时也是那个在索姆河战役中战斗的家伙。是的。我的意思是，你可以——但你可以更进一步说，尤其是在英语世界中，托尔金对中世纪在公众中的理解所产生的影响，可能比20世纪的任何其他人都大。是的。我的意思是，你可以画一条线，从沃尔特·司各特，通过托尔金，一直画到现在电视上的《权力的游戏》。是的。所以沃尔特·司各特，我可以说，将是他唯一的竞争对手，作为一个
who has influenced the popular understanding of what the Middle Ages were like. So I think for all those reasons, he's absolutely a valid subject of study for a history podcast. But I think precisely because he does kind of generate animus as well as devotion, it's probably worth our while just describing the kind of the parabola of our relationship with him, which is actually quite similar, isn't it? So presumably you read him as a boy. Yes, The Hobbit first um i first encountered the hobbit on jack and ory so um some listeners may remember jack and ory that ran on the bbc where people read bits of stories so i read the hobbit and then i read the lord of the rings i think i'd read the lord of
影响了公众对中世纪样貌理解的人。所以我认为出于所有这些原因，他绝对是历史播客的一个有效研究对象。但我想，正因为他确实既能激起敌意又能激起热爱，我们或许很有必要描述一下我们与他之间关系的发展轨迹，其实相当相似，不是吗？所以你大概在童年时读过他？是的，先是《霍比特人》嗯，我最早是在 BBC 的《Jackanory》节目中接触到《霍比特人的》——所以嗯，一些听众可能还记得在 BBC 播出的《Jackanory》，人们会在上面朗读故事片段——所以我读了《霍比特人》，然后我读了《指环王》，我想我读《指环王》的时候，
the rings certainly by the time i was about 10 or 11 um and and like a lot of people who read at that age especially sort of small boys who love stories of battles. Nerdy history boys. Yeah, nerdy history boys. Thank you, Tom. I immediately, it became enshrined right away in my mind as the best book. As the best book I had written. I had, yeah, absolutely.
肯定在我10岁或11岁左右的时候，嗯，而且就像许多在这个年龄读书的人一样，特别是那些喜欢战争故事的小男孩。书呆子历史男孩。是的，书呆子历史男孩。谢谢你，汤姆。我立刻，它就在我的心中被奉为最好的书。作为我写过的最好的书。我有，是的，绝对的。
And of course, do I still think that? No. But it's probably still my sentimental favorite. It would be my comfort read. And actually, I'd never thought about it in a sort of critical way at all until about probably in my 20s. And I read a great scholar called Tom Shippey, himself a great scholar of Anglo-Saxon. Who succeeded to Tolkien's academic – Yeah, so he's professor of – what was it?
当然，我现在还这么觉得吗？不。但它可能仍然是我情感上的最爱。它会是我的舒适读物。事实上，直到我大概20多岁时，我才以一种批判的方式思考过它。我读了一位伟大的学者的书，他叫汤姆·希佩（Tom Shippey），他本人就是一位伟大的盎格鲁-撒克逊语学者。他接替了托尔金的学术——是的，所以他是——什么来着？
The Bosworth – something Bosworth what was it, the Bosworth, something Bosworth, Rawlinson and Bosworth, professor of Anglo-Saxon. Right, and he basically wrote a couple of books, one which said Tolkien's work is all rooted in his scholarly study,
博斯沃思——某种博斯沃思，是什么来着，博斯沃思，某种博斯沃思，罗林森和博斯沃思，盎格鲁-撒克逊语教授。对，他基本上写了几本书，其中一本说托尔金的作品完全扎根于他的学术研究中，
in his study of languages. And I found that absolutely fascinating. And then he wrote a second book called J.R.R. Tolkien, Author of the Century, where he was talking about Tolkien as a very specifically 20th century writer, as a writer of the world wars and of the age of modernism. And I found that absolutely fascinating. And since then, I've thought, you know, how odd it is that Tolkien suffers from the condescension of sort of academic posterity when he's so clearly a really,
扎根于他的语言研究。我发现这绝对令人着迷。然后他写了第二本书，叫做《世纪作家 J.R.R. 托尔金》（J.R.R. Tolkien: Author of the Century），在书中他将托尔金视为一个非常具体的20世纪作家，作为世界大战和现代主义时代的作家。我发现这绝对令人着迷。从那以后，我想，你知道，托尔金受到学术后世的某种居高临下的态度是多么奇怪，而他分明是一个非常、非常有趣的人物和作家。
really interesting character and writer. I was going to say, when I read the Tom Shippey book on author of the century, I think he calls him that, doesn't he? Because there'd been a poll of the general public in 1999 to find out- Tolkien always wins these polls, doesn't he? And Tolkien always won. And lots of kind literary taste-setters were indignant about this. I remember reading and thinking, this is such a Sandbrook theme. He'd be so on Tolkien's side against whoever it was, sticking up for Virginia Woolf or whatever. Exactly. Tolkien has always suffered from this sort of...
我正要说的是，当我读汤姆·希佩关于世纪作家的那本书时，我想他就是这么称呼他的，对吧？因为1999年公众曾做过一次民意调查，为了找出——托尔金总是赢得这些民意调查，不是吗？托尔金总是赢。许多高雅的文学品味设定者对此感到愤怒。我记得我读到时想，这真是太桑德布鲁克式的主题了。他肯定会站在托尔金这边，不管对方是谁，力挺弗吉尼亚· Woolf 还是别的什么。没错。托尔金总是遭受这种……
I remember when Tolkien won the... I think it was the Waterstones at an end of century poll. And he won, as he always does, by a canter. And Germaine Greer was quoted saying, I have dreaded this. You know, I've dreaded this moment. I knew this would happen. And I sort of thought, well, isn't it interesting then to say, well, why did it happen? Rather than just to bemoan it. I mean, the interesting question is why?
我记得当托尔金赢得……我想那是世纪末 Waterstones（水石书店）的民意调查。正如他一贯的那样，他以压倒性优势获胜。杰曼·格里尔（Germaine Greer）曾被引述说：“我一直害怕这个。你知道，我一直害怕这一刻。我知道会发生这种事。”而我当时想，好吧，那么去探究“为什么会发生”，不是很有趣吗？而不是一味地哀叹。我的意思是，有趣的问题是为什么？
And we'll go on to discuss that later. But it's very you saying, you know, Sound of Music outsold Sgt. Pepper. It's the classic Sandbrook manoeuvre. So I was also, I loved The Hobbit, but I had a particular reason for reading Lord of the Rings, which was that my father, his first job as a solicitor was in Oxford, and he had to take Tolkien's will to him. So he took him to, Tolkienlkien had this garage and they went in and discussed the will um and and also the other thing is that we lived i think for the
我们稍后会讨论这一点。但你说“《音乐之声》的销量超过了《Sgt. Pepper》（佩珀中士）”，这非常符合你的风格。这是标准的桑德布鲁克式操作。所以我也很喜欢《霍比特人》，但我读《指环王》有一个特殊的原因，那就是我父亲，他在牛津找到的第一份律所工作，而他必须把托尔金的遗嘱送给托尔金。所以他把托尔金带到了那个车库，他们进去讨论了遗嘱，嗯，还有一件事是，我们住的——我想我生命的头几个月，我们住在一个叫布里尔（Brill）的村庄，它位于牛津的东边，意思是，所以它是布里山——所以布里这个名字出现在了《指环王》里，不是吗？当然，托尔金去世时是个相当富有的人，汤姆，所以他的遗嘱是一份很有分量的文件。无论如何，我的父亲虽然知道他但从未读过他的书，所以当我表达我想读《指环王》时，他相当热心，于是我们一起读了它——所以正如你所知，这对我来说是一个非常棒的美好记忆。我一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地读它，然后我把它抛在一边，就像对待幼稚的把戏一样。
first few months of my life we lived in a village called brill which is um east of oxford and means so it's brie hill so brie is the brie is appears in the lord of the rings isn't it and of course tolkien died quite a rich man tom so his will was a document of some consequence so anyway so my father who was aware of him but had never read him and so when i said i wanted to read lord of the rings he was quite keen and so we read it together um so i have that as you know it's kind of very it's great memory for me and i read it again and again and again and then i kind of cast it aside as I would childish things. That was very much my feeling kind of the Viking, the Norse myths and things, which are incredibly important to the fabric of Lord of the Rings,
这非常符合我的感受，比如维京人、北欧神话等等，它们对《指环王》的构建有着难以置信的重要作用，
but also all kinds of historical episodes, sieges of Constantinople, sieges of Augsburg by the Magyars, all this kind of stuff that suddenly I understood where all these elements in Lord of the Rings were coming from. Kind of like the mingling of different themes that you get, say, in TSA, it's the wasteland. And we talked about Tolkien as a kind of 20th century author. I think there's a really strong element of that. It's just that
还有各种历史插曲，君士坦丁堡之围、马扎尔人对奥格斯堡的围困，所有这些元素突然让我明白了《指环王》中所有这些元素的来源。有点像你在艾略特的《荒原》中看到的各种主题的交融。我们谈到托尔金作为一个20世纪的作家。我认为这里有一个非常强烈的因素。只是他借鉴的
he's drawing on much, much more obscure reaches of history and language than say, Eliot was or someone like that. And then when I wrote Dominion, I needed someone that the theme of Christianity and the horrors of the Second World War and the Third Reich and all that kind of stuff. And I actually thought Tolkien would be perfect for that because, of course, he was a very devout Christian. He was very devout Catholic. And I think that's a really, really important part, not just of how and why he comes to write what he does, but actually, I think also of his appeal. So maybe come to that later. Yeah, his books have, once you see it, you can't unsee it, the kind of spiritual dimension to them, I think. So as preparation for writing that chapter, I reread Lord of the Rings for the first time
历史和语言的领域要比艾略特或类似的人晦涩得多。后来当我写《多米尼克》（Dominion）时，我需要一个关于基督教主题、第二次世界大战和第三帝国的恐怖以及所有这些内容的人物。我其实觉得托尔金非常适合这一点，因为，当然，他是一个非常虔诚的基督徒。他是一个非常虔诚的天主教徒。我认为这是非常、非常重要的一部分，不仅关于他如何以及为什么写下他所写的东西，实际上，我认为这也是他吸引力的一部分。所以我们也许稍后再谈这个。是的，他的书有一种——一旦你看到了，你就无法忽视它——精神维度，我认为。因此，作为写那一章的准备，我重新阅读了《指环王》，这是我大约13岁以来的第一次。我惊叹于我漏掉了那么多，惊叹于它以一种非常、非常迷人的方式，如此清晰地为20世纪中叶的恐怖做一面镜子。所以我确信我们会谈到这一点。让我们从托尔金开始吧。所以我们对那些还没有抛弃我们的听众的计划是，因为他们对精灵感到恐惧，我们将谈论托尔金，
since I must have been about 13. And I was stunned at how much I had missed, stunned at how clearly it holds a mirror up to the horrors of the mid-20th century, really, really in a really fascinating way. So I'm sure we'll come to that. Let's start with Tolkien. So our plan for those listeners who haven't deserted us because they're terrified of elves is we'll talk about Tolkien
然后我们再去谈论这些书和其中的主题。这是一项需要做两期播客的工作。所以，系好安全带。我们在破晓时出发。其实应该有三期，诸如此类。本来就应该是。嗯，它应该是一个三部曲，尽管托尔金本人讨厌
and then we'll go on to talk about the books and the themes. And this is a two-podcast job. So, gird your loins. We ride a daybreak. It should really be three, so on and so forth. It should be. Well, it should be a trilogy, although Tolkien himself hated
《指环王》被称为三部曲，因为他将其构思为一个单一的作品。无论如何，听着，我们不想太快陷入书呆子气中。所以，是的，汤姆，让我们先来谈谈托尔金。说也奇怪，对于一个非常地道的英国人、一个认为自己是一个极其地道的英国作家并且梦想是为英格兰创造一个神话体系的人来说，
The Lord of the Rings being described as a trilogy because he conceived of it as a single work. Anyway, listen, we don't want to disappear into nerdishness too soon. So, yeah, let's start, Tom, by talking about Tolkien. And funnily enough, for a very English, for somebody who believed himself to be an intensely English writer and whose dream was to create a mythology of and for England,
他却有一个德国姓氏。所以他是日耳曼血统。我想他的祖先来自格但斯克，对吧？嗯，只有一方。是的。所以是他父亲这一边。没错。但他母亲这一边，萨菲尔（Suffield），来自埃夫舍姆。
he had a German surname. So he's a Germanic stock. I think his ancestors came from Gdansk, Gdansk, didn't they? Well, only one side. Yes. So his father's side. That's right. But his mother's side, Suffield, came from Evesham.
他们是米德兰人。所以托尔金完全搁置了德国的那一边。这全是因为他来自麦西亚。是的。但当你深入了解他的家族史时，这是可以理解的，正如我们将要做的。但另一件有趣的事情是，他实际上并不是出生在米德兰兹，甚至不是出生在英格兰。
They're Midlanders. And so Tolkien totally parked on one side, the German side. It was all about the fact that he'd come from Mercia. Yeah. But that's understandable when you get into his family history, as we will. But the other thing that's interesting is that he's not actually born in the Midlands or indeed in England.
实际上，他是一个帝国的儿子，因为他出生在南非，在布隆方丹，那是哪一年，1892年。他的父亲亚瑟，一个非常典型的维多利亚时代的人，名字很说明问题，留着耸人听闻的胡子，嗯，在银行工作，不是吗？我认为可以说他是一个非常不迷人的人。是的，是的，罗罕的银行家，这听起来不太——所以他们搬去了南非，我想我猜他们在开普敦结了婚，
He is a son of empire, actually, because he's born in South Africa, in Bloemfontein in, what is it, 1892. And his father, Arthur, very good Victorian, very telling name a sensational mustache yeah um worked in a bank didn't he he was a very i think it's fair to say a very unglamorous man yeah yeah the banker of rohan it doesn't so they so they had moved out to south africa um i think i guess they got married in Cape town,
他的父母。是的。所以，亚瑟当时在那儿工作。然后梅贝尔，他的母亲，也去那里和他会合。他们，
his parents. Yeah. So he, so Arthur was working out there to begin with. And then Mabel, who was his mother, went out to join him. And they,
是的，他们，所以在开普敦结了婚，度了蜜月，然后定居在布隆方丹，亚瑟很喜欢这里，而梅贝尔则恨透了。是的。实际上，所以她，
yeah, they, so they got married in Cape town, had a honeymoon and then settled in Bloemfontein, which Arthur loved and Mabel hated. Yeah. And actually, so she,
她太讨厌这里了，当——所以他叫约翰·罗纳德·鲁尔·托尔金。所以当小罗纳德——当他的朋友们叫他小罗纳德，或者约翰·罗纳德，当他大概——他几岁？他刚满三岁。梅贝尔决定回到英格兰。此时他还有一个弟弟，希拉里。是的，希拉里。是希拉里吗？
she hates it so much that when, so he's crossing John Ronald rule Tolkien. So when young Ronald, as he when, so he's crossing John Ronald Rule Tolkien. So when young Ronald, as his friends call him, or John Ronald, when he's about, what is he, about three? He's just turned three. Mabel decides to go back to England. And he's got a younger brother by this point as well, Hillary. Yes, Hillary. Is it Hillary?
是的，是希拉里。带着希拉里。于是他们启程前往英格兰。计划是亚瑟会加入他们，基本上当他——我猜——办完银行的手续或其他事情之后。这个计划没有实现，因为他在基本上甚至还没登上船之前就死于风湿热。所以梅贝尔突然回到了英格兰的老家，成了一个寡妇，确切地说，带着这两个非常小的男孩。但对于托尔金的故事，以及他的小说的起源来说，接下来重要的事情是，他们住在哪里，因为他们住在一个叫做——你曾经去过萨霍尔（Sarehole）吗，汤姆？你去过萨霍尔磨坊吗？不，我没有。但我实际上读了很多关于它的书，我现在很想去。所以那是当时北伍斯特郡的一个村庄，在伯明翰的边缘。伯明翰，伟大的维多利亚城市。
Yes, it is Hillary. With Hillary. So off they go to England. And the plan is that Arthur will join them, basically, when he's, I guess, served out his notice with the bank or whatever it is. And that plan does not work out because he dies of rheumatic fever before he's even basically boarded the ship. So suddenly Mabel is back home in England, a widow exactly, with these two very small boys. But what's important then for Tolkien's story, and indeed for the genesis of his fiction,
约瑟夫·张伯伦的城市。喷吐着烟雾。将自己视为帝国的第一个城市，一个庞大的城市利维坦。工业的喧嚣与碰撞。Exactly。车轮转动。是的。而他们就在边缘。
is where they live, because they live in a place called... Have you ever been to Serhol, Tom? Have you been to Serhol Mill? No, I haven't. But I've actually been reading quite a lot about it, and I now want to go. So it was a village in what was then North Worcestershire on the fringes of Birmingham. Birmingham, the great Victorian city.
他们在……而托尔金……他们在那个小村庄长大，那里有一个带水车的磨坊，还有你可以奔跑和躲藏的小树林、草地和小溪。
Joseph Chamberlain's city. Pumping out smoke. Sees itself as the first city of the empire, a massive kind of urban leviathan. The din and the clash of industry. Exactly. Wheels turning. Yeah. And they're on the fringe.
这简直太田园诗般了，但显然也完全受到了城市扩张的威胁，甚至注定要被其毁灭。我的意思是，我认为其中一个……它显然对托尔金产生了极其震撼的影响。和城市。我的意思是，我认为其中一个原因，它显然对托尔金产生了极其震撼的影响。
They're on the... And Tolkien... And they grow up in this little village where it has a sort of a mill with a water wheel and little copses where you can run and hide and meadows and streams.
他说，我的意思是，他声称自己还记得它，因为他甚至还记得在南非的事情。所以正是这种对比让他爱上了英格兰，他说。现在这可能有点神话制造的成分，但毫无疑问，他对树木、对磨坊、对一切唤起沃里克郡乡村美景的事物有着非常、非常深的情感依恋。正如你所说，它受到工业侵蚀的威胁，这一点极其重要。
And it's completely idyllic, but it's also obviously completely threatened and indeed doomed by the expansion of the city. I mean, I think one of the... It has... It obviously has an absolutely seismic effect on Tolkien. And the city. I mean, I think one of the reasons, it obviously has an absolutely seismic effect on Tolkien.
这也是1890年代、1900年代英国生活的一个大主题。当时有很多作家都写过这个。所以H.G.威尔斯就是一个典型的例子。他写了布罗姆利（东南伦敦的一部分）遭遇了什么，被不断扩张的城市吞噬。这也是爱德华时代文学的一个大主题。同时，我认为托尔金对这个地方有着难以置信的情感依恋——这里基本上就是《霍比特人》和《指环王》中他的霍比特人所居住的夏尔的原型——原因在于他在进入十多岁之前就失去了它。因为他们搬出了萨霍尔。他们最终离伯明翰越来越近。然后他12岁时母亲去世了。是的。
And he says, I mean, he claims that he remembers it, coming to it because he also remembers being in South Africa. And so it's the contrast that makes him fall in love with England, he says. Now that may well be a bit of a kind of myth-making, but there's no question that he feels very, very emotionally tied to the trees, to the mills, to everything that evokes the beauties of rural Warwickshire. And as you say, the fact that it is menaced by the encroachment of industry is hugely important.
但他们搬家的原因之一，呃，有两个原因。一个是因为托尔金非常、非常聪明。他将进入爱德华国王学校（King Edward's），也就是伯明翰最好的文法学校，位于市中心。所以如果不这样，他走路的距离会很远。所以他们不得不搬得更近一些。但这也是因为——同样，这也是对托尔金的关键影响——他的母亲梅贝尔已经改信了天主教，所以他们需要去一座天主教教堂，这也是他们搬家的另一个原因，她和她的家人闹翻了，不是吗？她的家人非常反对这一点。
And that's a big theme of English life, by the way, in the 1890s, 1900s. Lots of writers at the time wrote about this. So HG Wells is the classic example. He writes about what happens to Bromley, sort of Southeast London, swallowed up by the expanding city. And that's a big theme of kind of Edwardian letters. But also the reason I think Tolkien has this incredibly sentimental attachment to this place, which is basically the prototype for the Shire, the place his hobbits come from in The Hobbit and The Lord of the Rings, I think is because he loses it before he's entered his teens. Because they move out of Serhal. They end up moving closer and closer to Birmingham. And then his mother dies when he's 12. Yeah.
他们是卫理公会信徒，卫理公会信徒，是的，我的意思是真的很不喜欢天主教。所以我认为年轻的托尔金将此经历为一种，你知道的，堕落。是的，绝对的。他接着说，每一个故事都是堕落。从恩典中堕落的概念，堕落，失去恩典，这是20世纪之交这个人口稠密的城市帝国社会、工业社会中英国写作的一个非常普遍的主题。所以他大概12岁时就成了孤儿，他和他的弟弟成了神父摩根神父（Father Morgan）的受监护人，他们最终搬去和一个姑妈同住，不是吗？我的意思是，为了让人们有个概念，任何了解伯明翰但不了解托尔金的人——他们基本上从那个“英格兰青翠可爱的大地”（那种树林和潺潺小溪之类的地方）搬到了现在离伯明翰市中心五路环岛（Five Ways roundabout）非常近的地方，这里有着巨大的喧嚣、工业和工厂。我的意思是，作为一种文学原型，这不仅仅是爱德华时代的，我的意思是，这有点像狄更斯式的，这是那种被送到黑鞋油厂级别的创伤，我认为。是的，而且——当然，在狄更斯的作品中，你也有变成孤儿的创伤，成年人作为压迫性的存在，正如你所说，年轻的托尔金去和他们的姑妈住在一起，这是一个非常没有同理心的角色，然后他们最终和一个——另一个同样——同样我认为一点也不母性、反而显得专制的女人住在一起，不是吗？所有这些，有点像罗尔德·达尔笔下的姑妈。
But one of the reasons why they, well, two reasons why they move. One is because Tolkien's very, very bright. And he is going to King Edward's, so the best grammar school in Birmingham, which is in the middle. So it's a long way for him to walk otherwise. So they have to move in closer. But also it's because, and again again this is a key influence on tolkien his mother mabel has converted to catholicism so they need to go to a catholic church and so that's the other reason that they move and she falls out with her family doesn't she her family really take against it
有点像《大卫·科波菲尔》。是的，就像罗尔德·达尔。具有那种特质。但也寄宿在第二个这种相当专制的姑妈家里的是一个叫伊迪丝·布拉特（Edith Bratt）的女孩，她一点也不调皮（brat）。她是一个非常安静、冷静、聪明的女孩，钢琴弹得非常好，比托尔金大三岁，他们疯狂地坠入爱河，而那个神父——神父——神父根本不同意这事，他禁止他们见面，不是吗？他们甚至不能交流
who are methodists methodists and yeah i mean really not keen on potpourri. And so I think the young Tolkien experiences this as a kind of, you know, the fall. Yes, absolutely. He goes on to say that every story is the fall. The idea of the fall from grace, the fall, the loss of grace, that is a very common theme of British writing in this densely populated urban imperial society, industrial society at the turn of the 20th century. so he's orphaned by the time he's what 12 um and he and his brother become wards of a catholic priest called father morgan and they basically end up moving in with an aunt don't they i mean to give people a sense anybody who knows birmingham but doesn't know tolkien um they basically move from the the sort of england's green and pleasant land sort of you know woods and babbling brooks and stuff they move to to what is now very close
或者有三年的时间——我的意思是，对青少年做出这种事简直太离谱了。但托尔金是一个非常严肃的人。你知道，他非常专注。我认为他在整个一生中都是如此。他花了许多青少年只是说，见鬼去吧，你知道，我要见你。是的，我跑了。不，他把这看得相当——我认为他违反过一次誓言去见她或与她交流。但除此之外，绝对严格遵守。我认为原因部分是因为弗神父有独立经济来源，并在帮助抚养这两个男孩。所以他对这一点心存感激，不想冒犯或惹恼他。而且我认为他也是一个非常、非常虔诚的天主教徒，在某种程度上，他已经开始沉迷于探寻和浪漫的想法中。所以他极其痴迷于亚瑟王文学、所有这些类似的东西。并且他觉得这是他和伊迪丝必须经历的一场考验。是的，他相当理想主义。他非常理想主义。而且在适当的时候，他会将他们的关系神话化，达到惊人的效果。无论如何，但这意味着，既然女孩们已经被暂时搁置在一旁，他就可以专注于做小伙子们做的事，那就是打橄榄球、和其他小伙子混在一起，谈论学术的事情。语言。
to the five ways roundabout in the center of birmingham so this kind of huge clamor and industry and factories and all that i mean as a as a kind of literary archetype it's not just edwardian is i mean this is kind of dickens this is off to the blacking factory kind of level of trauma i think yeah and and and also of course also you have in dickens the the trauma of being orphaned of adults as oppressive figures and as you say the young tolkien's go off to stay with their aunt who is a very unsympathetic figure and then they end up staying in a um with another woman who's equally who's equally i think not not maternal but they seem tyrannical, don't they? All these, they're sort of Roald Dahl aunts.
诸如此类的事情。所以我们说过他去了爱德华国王伯明翰学校，这是一所历史悠久、闻名遐迩、声誉卓著的私立文法学校。他加入了，我想有两个组织真的很重要。如果你想了解更多这方面的信息，我知道我们都读过并非常喜欢约翰·加思（John Garth）的书。他写了一本关于托尔金与大战的精彩书籍，而大战不仅关乎大战，也关乎托尔金和爱德华时代
Kind of David Copperfield. Yeah, so Roald Dahl. It's that kind of quality. But also lodged with the second of these rather tyrannical aunts is a girl called Edith Bratt, who is not at all a brat. She's a very quiet, calm, clever girl who's very very good at piano um three years older than tolkien and they fall madly in love and the priest the priest the priest is not having it at all he bans them from seeing each other doesn't he and they can't communicate
以及他所就读的学校。他加入的其中一个组织是学员部队（cadet force）。所以这是一件非常具有爱德华时代特征的事情。加思找到了这张照片，显示托尔金在1907年15岁时，穿着军装，显得非常苍白和严肃，那天是大英帝国的伟大英雄、赢得无数胜利、赢得布尔战争的陆军元帅罗伯茨勋爵（Field Marshal Lord Roberts）来学校访问，所有的男孩都列队站着，托尔金就在那里。
or something for three years i mean an absolutely extraordinary thing to do to teenagers. But Tolkien's quite a, he's a very serious person. You know, he's very intense. And I think that's true throughout his life. And he takes a lot of teenagers just say, sod you, you know, I'm going to see you. Yeah, I'm running off. But no, he takes this quite, I think he breaks the vow once to see her or to communicate with her. But otherwise, absolutely adheres to it. And I think the reason for that is partly because Father Francis has independent means and is helping to keep the boys. So he feels grateful for that, doesn't want to offend or upset him. And I think also he's very,
他们正在为战争接受训练。他们有一种感觉，战争即将来临，英国将受到考验，他们也将受到考验。他们在学校做的每一件事实际上都在为之做准备。正如你所说，在橄榄球场上，那种同志情谊、尽自己的一份力、成为团队的一部分，所有这些东西。毫无疑问，托尔金……奋力拼搏，奋力拼搏，把游戏玩好。
very devout Catholic and feels, in a way, he's already getting into the idea of quests and romance. So he's passionately devoted to Arthurian literature, all that kind of stuff. And I think he feels that this is a test that he and Edith have to go through. Yeah, he's quite idealistic. He's very idealistic. And in due course, he will mythologize their relationship to spectacular effect. Anyway, but what that does mean is that now that girls have been parked to one side, he can focus on doing what chaps do, which is play rugger and hang out with other chaps and talk about scholarly things. Languages.
奋力拼搏，奋力拼搏，把游戏玩好。毫无疑问，托尔金非常认真地对待这一切。我认为帝国和为国家服务、为国王和国家服务，是他的世界观中非常重要的一部分，即使那是潜意识的。我认为这不可能是别的。好吧，我的意思是，这只是一个提醒，因为《指环王》最终成了60年代嬉皮士的最爱，但托尔金最早、最生动的记忆之一，是萨霍尔（Sarehole）点燃了篝火和烟花来庆祝维多利亚女王的登基钻禧庆典，
Stuff like that. So we said he goes to the school King Edward's Birmingham, long established, famous, prestigious private grammar school. And he joins, I think there's two organizations that really matter. And if you want to read more about this, I know we've both read and hugely enjoyed the books by John Garth. He wrote a fantastic book about Tolkien at the Great War, and the Great War is not just about the Great War, it's also about Tolkien and the Edwardian period
而这将会为《指环王》的开篇提供养分——所以你知道，他有着漫长的人生，他在这战前社会中的根基是真的很深、真的很强烈。但同时，他已经开始在一个非常遥远的世界里生活了，所以我认为，不是吗？他进行骑马训练，虽然他其实并不擅长这个，但他有过随骑兵骑马的经历——所以这显然是伴随着他的东西。而且他——我的意思是他在学拉丁语和希腊语，正如他那个年龄和阶层的文法学校的所有男孩所做的那样，嗯，但他同时也迷上了日耳曼语言，所以他们有学校戏剧，每个人都必须用拉丁语交谈，但他却出现并用哥特语交谈——我认为——这相当老成，但他当时
and the school that he goes to. And one of the things he joins is the cadet force. So this is a very Edwardian thing. So Garth has found this photo that shows Tolkien in 1907 at the age of 15, looking very pale and very serious in his military uniform on the day that Field Marshal Lord Roberts, the great hero of the British Empire, the man who'd won endless victories, who'd won the Boer War, he comes to visit the school and all the boys are lined up and Tolkien is right there.
17岁左右吧？几乎什么都不剩了，他甚至——我不认为——我想他接触哥特语甚至可能更早。我的意思是，这绝对是非同寻常的。几乎没有留下什么用哥特语写的东西。它的很多部分都丢失了，而他变得完全沉迷于其中。他有一群朋友，不是吗？他们聚在一起喝茶，在一个叫巴罗商店（Barrow's Stores）的地方聚会，在一家百货公司里。所以这是一个茶话俱乐部和一个巴罗商店，TCBCs。
They are being trained for war. They have a sense that a war is coming and that Britain will be tested and that they will be tested. Everything they do at school really is preparing them for this. As you said, on the rugby field, the sense of camaraderie, doing your bit, being part of the team, all of this stuff. And Tolkien undoubtedly... Play up, play up, and play the game.
抱歉，TCBSs。茶话俱乐部巴罗维亚协会（The Tea Club Barovian Society），我想他们是这么叫自己的。有四个核心成员，他就是其中之一。当你读约翰·加思的书时，他重现了他们大量的信件等等，我的意思是，以青少年的标准来看，他们是非常高度理想主义的。他们是唯美主义者吗？这其中有一点那种成分，唯美主义。他们是唯美主义者吗？
Play up, play up, and play the game. Tolkien undoubtedly takes this very seriously. And I think the empire and serving your country, serving king and country, is a huge part of his worldview, actually, even if it's unconscious. I think it could not be otherwise. Well, I mean, just a reminder of, because Lord of the Rings ends up being the toast of hippies in the 60s. But one of Tolkien's earliest and most vivid memories is of a sailhole being lit up with bonfires and fireworks to celebrate queen victoria's jubilee
这其中有一点那种成分，但他们不仅仅是唯美主义者。所以他们回溯到北欧人和盎格鲁-撒克逊人的世界等等。在这一点上，他们身上带有维多利亚时代人的印记，不是吗？我认为实际上他们对唯美主义者的想法有着相当大的敌意。所以在适当的时候，托尔金将成为粗呢西服（Baggy Tweed）和其他类似东西的超级狂热爱好者。我认为这是一种有意识的愿望，想要与船的那一边划清界限。同样，所以我们有很多问题
and that will feed into the opening of lord of the rings so you know he has a long life and and his roots in this pre-war society are really really strong really intense but already he is also starting to inhabit a very distant world so i think isn't he he he does he trains on horseback and he's not actually very good at that but he's had experience of kind of riding with cavalry so that's something obviously that stays with him and he's also i mean he's doing latin and greek as as all boys of his age and and class at grammar school would do um but he's also become obsessed by germanic languages and so they do they have this school play where everyone has to talk in latin but he turns up and talks in gothic which i think i mean that's pretty precocious but he was
说托尔金似乎对女性没有太大的兴趣。我们可能会在以后谈到这一点，但女性在《指环王》或《霍比特人》中并不显眼。我认为他将伊迪丝作为伟大的浪漫痴迷对象——我的意思是，她对她来说极其重要。但在某种程度上，正因为他把这部分理清了并且被边缘化了，
17 or something yeah there's virtually nothing left he's not even i don't think i think he finds got gets into gothic possibly even before before that when he's even younger. I mean, it's absolutely extraordinary. There's virtually nothing written in Gothic that remains. It's a sort of loads of bits of it are lost, and he becomes completely obsessed by it. And he's got this group of friends, hasn't he? They meet for tea, and they meet in a place called Barrow's Stores, in a department store. So it's a tea club and a Barrow's store, the TCBCs.
他现在可以专注于仅仅和伙伴们混在一起。是的。那种非常激烈的男性同伴情谊，这是一种非常爱德华时代的现象，不是吗？是的，他非常热衷于此，嗯，所以在适当的时候，他获得了去牛津的奖学金，他去了埃克塞特学院（Exeter），和另外两个人同一所学院，我认为他们是托尔金极好的先驱——其中一个非常有名，威廉·莫里斯（William Morris），伟大的维多利亚时代全才。我们在一个度假播客中谈论过莫里斯去冰岛的事。当然，莫里斯正是那个真正让冰岛萨迦及类似作品在接下来的几十年里受到理想主义年轻人追捧的人。换句话说，也就是托尔金那一代人。
Sorry, TCBSs. The Tea Club Barovian Society, I think they call themselves. And there's four key members and he's one of them. And they are, when you read John Garth's book and he reproduces lots of their letters and so on, I mean, they're very, by adolescent standards, they are intensely idealistic. Are they Aesthetes? There's a bit of that about them, butistic. Are they Aesthetes?
另一个也毕业于爱德华国王学校的人是画家爱德华·伯恩-琼斯（Edward Burne-Jones）。他痴迷于中世纪，痴迷于亚瑟王，痴迷于所有这些东西。他是一个前拉斐尔派。是的。那种致力于高尚中世纪主义的群体理念，绝对是托尔金和他的朋友们所笃信的。所以对他们来说，这不仅仅是一个业余爱好。这是晚期维多利亚和爱德华时代英国文化中非常普遍的一种现象，即对工业、机械时代和城市现代性的反感，以及对骑士、圣骑士和少女的失落世界的某种理想化。
There's a bit of that about them, but they're not just Aesthetes. So they're looking back to the world of the Norse and the Anglo-Saxons and so on. And in that, they bear the imprints of the Victorians, don't they? I think that there's actually quite a hostility to the idea of being an Aesthete. So in due course, Tolkien will be a great enthusiast for Baggy Tweed and all that kind of stuff. I think it's a kind of conscious desire to have nothing to do with that side of ship. As also, so we had quite a lot of questions
他们身上确实有那么一点影子，但他们绝不仅仅是唯美主义者。所以他们回顾的是北欧人和盎格鲁-撒克逊人的世界等等。在这个意义上，他们带有维多利亚时代人的印记，不是吗？我认为实际上他们对唯美主义者的身份相当排斥。所以在适当的时候，托尔金会非常热衷于宽大的粗花呢服饰之类的一切。我认为这是一种有意识的渴望，想与那种调调划清界限。正如我们也有相当多的问题
saying Tolkien doesn't seem to be tremendously interested in women. We might come to that later, but women don't feature prominently in Lord of the Rings or indeed in The Hobbit. And I think that the fact that he has Edith as this great romantic object of devotion, I mean, she's incredibly important to him. But in a way, precisely because he's got that sorted and got bit marginalized,
说托尔金似乎对女性没有太大的兴趣。我们待会儿可能会谈到这一点，但女性在《魔戒》甚至《霍比特人》中并不占重要地位。我认为，虽然他有伊迪丝作为他伟大的浪漫痴迷对象——我的意思是，她在对他是极其重要的——但在某种程度上，正因为他在情感上有了着落并将其边缘化，
he can now focus on just hanging out with chaps. Yes. And that kind of very intense masculine camaraderie which is a very edwardian thing isn't it yeah he buys into that hugely um and so in due course he gets a scholarship to go to oxford he goes to the same college exeter as two people who i think are excellent kind of precursors for tolkien so one of them very famous will William Morris, the great kind of Victorian polymath. We talked about Morris to Iceland in a holiday podcast. And of course, Morris is the person who really makes the Icelandic sagas and things trendy for idealistic younger people in the decades that follow. So in other words, of Tolkien's generation.
他现在可以专注于和哥们儿厮混了。是的。那种非常强烈的男性情谊，是非常爱德华时代风格的东西，对吧？是的，他非常接受这一点。因此，不久之后他获得了去牛津的奖学金，他进入了埃克塞特学院，这也是另外两个我认为是托尔金的绝佳先驱的人所在的学院——其中一个非常著名，就是伟大的维多利亚时代博学家威廉·莫里斯。我们在一个假期播客中谈到过莫里斯去冰岛。当然，莫里斯正是那个在接下来的几十年里，真正让冰岛萨迦和其他东西在理想主义的年轻人中流行起来的人。换句话说，他属于托尔金的那一代。
And the other person who also went to King Edward's is the painter Edward Burne-Jones. And he's obsessed with, you know, the medieval, with King Arthur, with all that stuff. And he's a pre-Raphaelite. Yes. And that idea of a group devoted to high-minded medievalism is absolutely something that Tolkien and his friends buy into. So it's more than a hobby for them. It's a very common thing in late Victorian Edwardian British culture, this revulsion from industry and from the machine age and from urban modernity and this sort of idealization of a lost world of knights and paladins and maidens.
另一个也去过爱德华国王学校的人是画家爱德华·伯恩-琼斯。他痴迷于中世纪、亚瑟王以及所有这些东西。他是一个拉斐尔前派成员。是的。而那种致力于崇高中世纪主义的群体理念，绝对是托尔金和他的朋友们所接受的。所以对他们来说，这不仅仅是一个爱好。在维多利亚时代晚期和爱德华时代的英国文化中，这是一种非常普遍的现象——这种对工业、机械时代和城市现代性的反感，以及对骑士、圣骑士和少女的失落世界的某种理想化。
And I mean, you see that everywhere in late Victorian culture. An incredibly intense experience of friendship. So two of them go to Oxford, including Tolkien, two of them go to oxford including tolkien two of them go to cambridge and they kind of meet up at regular intervals and it's this so one of them's a poet one of them tolkien is is thinking of becoming a philologist um one of the painter i mean it's it's one of them's a musician it's this idea that they will you know they take themselves very very very seriously um and the fact that they all equally you know they all take themselves seriously and they all sustain each other in their sense that what they're doing is important i think is you know especially when you think central to their they're 19 they haven't done
我是说，你在晚期维多利亚文化中随处可见那种极其强烈的友谊体验。他们当中有两个人去了牛津，包括托尔金，还有两个人去了剑桥，他们会定期聚会，其中一个是诗人，托尔金当时在考虑成为一名语言学家，还有一个是画家，还有一个是音乐家，这种想法就是他们会，你知道的，他们非常非常严肃地对待自己，而且他们所有人也都一样，你知道的，他们都对自己很认真，并且在他们所做的事情很重要这一点上互相支持，我认为你知道的，尤其是当你想到这是他们核心的——他们当时19岁，还没做过
anything yeah they're just writing poems to read at their little meetings but as you say they to them everything they write is sort of loaded with this cosmological um importance and tolkien is already writing some of the stuff i think so 1914 he writes the first what what looks now like the first fragment of this great corpus of legends. Do you have it? Do you have the Old English? I don't have the Old English. Are you going to read it, Tom? Yeah.
什么。是的，他们只是写诗在他们的小聚会上朗读，但正如你所说，对他们来说，他们写的每一切都似乎承载着这种宇宙学般的重任，而托尔金当时已经在写一些东西了，我想是的，1914年他写了看起来像是这个庞大传说体系的第一篇残篇。你有吗？你有古英语吗？我没有古英语。你打算读它吗，汤姆？是的。
Go on. So this is from a poem by Kinnewulf called Christ. Eala Earendel Englabertast of a Mittengard monum sended so that's uh hail a arendel um brightest of angels over middle earth uh you have been sent to man to mankind to men so so that's not tolkien is it that's anglo-saxon that's anglo-saxon but the question is what is a arendel and tolkien is pondering this in 1914 whereas he's on the lizard i think isn't isn't he? He's on a holiday on the lizard, somewhere like that. And he wrote about it in a piece of fiction that he published later. He said, I felt a curious thrill.
说吧。所以这是基内武夫的一首名为《基督》的诗：Eala Earendel Englabertast of a Mittengard monum sended... 所以那是，呃，万岁，埃伦德尔——最明亮的的天使，在中土之上——你被派往人间，派往人类——所以，那不是托尔金，对吧？那是盎格鲁-撒克逊语。那是盎格鲁-撒克逊语，但问题是，埃伦德尔是什么？托尔金在1914年思考这个问题时，我想他正在莉兹德（The Lizard）半岛吧，不是吗？他在莉兹德度假，类似那样的地方。他把他后来出版的一部小说中写到了这件事。他说：“我感到一种奇怪的颤栗。”
So reading those lines, I felt a curious thrill as if something had stirred in me, half wakened from sleep. There was something very remote and strange and beautiful behind these words if i could grasp it far beyond ancient english um and that question of of who or what aurendal is haunts him and in one level it's it's christ but in another level maybe it's you know it's the morning star or the evening star it's a star that enables navigators to follow as they sail out into the Atlantic. And so he writes this poem, doesn't he, in which Earendal is a mariner, and is setting out across the ocean, rather, as the Irish saints had done. And I think, Tom, if history had played out differently, we wouldn't be doing this podcast, and this poem would be utterly forgotten. But that very summer,
所以读到这些诗句时，我感到一种奇怪的颤栗，仿佛有什么东西在我体内苏醒，从睡眠中半醒过来。这些词汇背后有着非常遥远、陌生而美丽的东西，如果我能抓住它的话，远远超越了古代英语。而关于“谁”或“什么”是埃伦德尔的那个问题一直困扰着他，在某种程度上它是基督，但在另一个层面也许它是晨星或晚星，这是一颗能够指引航海家驶入大西洋时跟随的星星。于是他写了这首诗，不是吗？诗中的埃伦德尔是一个水手，正扬帆远航横渡大洋，正如爱尔兰圣徒们曾经做过的那样。我想，汤姆，如果历史以不同的方式发展，我们今天就不会在做这个播客，这首诗也会被彻底遗忘。但就在那个夏天，
that's the summer of the assassination of Sarajevo, of the slide to war. And I think it's the First World War and what happens next to Tolkien that completely, it doesn't change his trajectory, but it gives it a charge that it would not otherwise have had. And it's that, I think, that is the defining and the seismic moment in his life. And I think we should come to that after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
那是萨拉热窝刺杀事件的夏天，是滑向战争的夏天。我认为正是第一次世界大战以及接下来发生在托尔金身上的事情，彻底——它没有改变他的轨迹，但它赋予了它一种原本不会有的能量。我认为，这才是他生命中决定性的、震撼性的时刻。我想我们应该在休息之后再谈这个。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐其余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about the life and times of J.R.R. Tolkien and we've got as far as the First World War. So Tolkien's instinct when war breaks
以及少许的八卦八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的其余》（The Rest Is History）。我们正在讨论J.R.R.托尔金的生平与时代，我们已经讲到了第一次世界大战。所以托尔金在战争爆发时的直觉，
out, interestingly, is not to rush to the battlefront, is it? Because he's very conscious that he wants an academic career and he doesn't want to rush off and jeopardize that and not graduate and not get the qualifications he needs. So he leaves it a year or so and he starts to get hints from his relatives. I know everybody else is at the war where what are you doing but he i mean he basically he signs up but he can put it on hold yes so there's no question that that once he's finished his degree he will go so he gets his degree he gets a very good first which means that he will be able to pursue an academic career should he survive the conflict but in 1915 he he is commissioned and he joins the Signals. And Gordon Crowe will be very excited to know that among all the other skills that he learns as a Signals officer, he learns
有趣的是，并不是冲向战前线，对吧？因为他非常清楚自己想要学术生涯，他不想冲过去危及这一切，导致无法毕业，拿不到他需要的资质。所以他耽搁了一年左右，并开始从亲戚那里得到暗示。我知道所有其他人都在参战，你在干什么呢？但他基本上——他报名参进了，但他可以把它搁置。是的，毫无疑问，一旦他完成学位他就会去，所以他拿到了学位，拿到了非常优异的一等学位，这意味着如果他在冲突中幸存下来，他将能够追求学术生涯；但在1915年，他被委任军官并加入了通讯兵部队。戈登·克罗一定会非常兴奋地得知，在他作为通讯兵学到的所有其他技能中，他学会了
to handle pigeons. So that's tremendous. If you're interested in pigeons, if you've come to this podcast for Tolkien, we have pigeons for you, would you believe, in the Restless History's back catalogue. But I mean, if you think about believe in the rest of history's back catalogue but i mean if you think about um lord of the rings there's quite a lot of birds and sending messages and things like that so tom i'm trying to drag you back from pigeons don't get into another piece of podcast so he's joined the 11th lancashire fusiliers because his friend has christopher is it christopher wiseman one of them has one of the the tcbss yes yes joined the lancashire fusiliers so all his friends have joined up the whole little group of them they and they has joined the Lancashire Fusiliers. So all his friends have joined up, the whole little group of them. And they believe in the war as a slightly idealistic crusade, don't they?
如何处理信鸽。所以这太棒了。如果你对信鸽感兴趣，如果你是为了托尔金来到这个播客的，你会相信吗，我们在《历史的其余》往期节目里还真有关于信鸽的内容。但我的意思是，如果你想想——相信《历史的其余》往期节目，但我的意思是，如果你想想《指环王》，里面有很多鸟类、传递信息之类的事情。所以，汤姆，我正试图把你从信鸽那里拉回来，别又扯到另一个播客去了。所以他加入了第11兰开夏燧发枪团，因为他的朋友——克里斯托弗是吗？克里斯托弗·怀斯曼，他们其中一人有——TCBS的成员之一，是的，加入了兰开夏燧发枪团。所以他所有的朋友都参军了，整个小群体都参军了。他们把这场战争视为一场略带理想主义的十字军东征，不是吗？
They believe a new Britain will be created at the end of the war, and it'll be their responsibility to do it. And so Tolkien and co. get posted to France, his battalion, in the summer of 1916, just in time, for the show that is being planned near Albert, which turns out to be the Battle of the Somme. And he's not there on the first day, but one of his friends, Robert Gilson, is. And he is killed on the first day. One of the 20,000 people, British soldiers who are killed on the very first day. And then Tolkien himself is inevitably drawn into the horror. And in John Garth's book, which we were talking about in the first part of this episode,
他们相信战争结束时会创造出一个新的英国，而这将是他们的责任去实现它。所以托尔金和他的伙伴们于1916年夏天被派往法国，加入他的营，正赶上在阿尔贝附近策划的那场大战，结果证明那就是索姆河战役。他在第一天不在场，但他的朋友罗伯特·吉尔森在场。他在第一天阵亡了。在第一天阵亡的2万名英国士兵之一。然后托尔金本人不可避免地被卷入了恐怖之中。在约翰·加思的书里——我们在本集第一部分讨论过的那本书——
he describes they're going into trenches littered with bodies, body parts, the mud, the rain, the horror. And for a young man, for an idealistic young man who's basically spent far too much time reading Finnish grammar books, this must have been an absolutely searing and indeed life-defining experience. And he's at the cutting edge of a number of seismic developments in the history of warfare that will then have obvious echoes for anyone who has read the novels or seen the films. So he's there on the 15th of September for the debut of the tank. Yeah. And tanks, when you think of the greatth of september for the debut of the tank yeah and tanks you know when you think of the great battering rams and the dragons and all the the huge elephants that's
他描述了他们进入战壕的场景，战壕里到处都是尸体、尸块、泥浆、雨水和恐怖。对于一个年轻人，一个基本上把太多时间花在阅读芬兰语语法书上的理想主义年轻人来说，这一定是一次极其痛苦且可以说是颠覆人生的经历。而且他处于战争史上一系列震撼性发展的最前沿，这对于任何读过小说或看过电影的人来说，都会产生明显的共鸣。所以他在9月15日亲历了坦克的首次亮相。是的。当你想起那些巨大的攻城锤、巨龙和所有巨大的大象时，坦克就是
something but but also he is he's there while the red baron is doing his stuff in the air overhead oh i hadn't thought of the red baron yeah so the so the red baron is is you know becoming the the great fighter ace of the uh of the air air and basically enables the German Air Force to win control of the battlefield. So that sense that there is danger in the air, which again is something that you get throughout Tolkien's fiction, the sense that danger lurks there um and in due course it won't be you know it's not planes but um witch kings on pterosaurs is what it will be but i mean it's it's pretty clear that the the you know the inspiration for that sense of terror isn't just you know medieval literature it's clearly coming from his experience on in in the trenches um As is also, the hobbits have to go to this land called Mordor for complicated reasons we won't go into
这么回事，但与此同时，当红男爵（Red Baron）在头顶的天空中大显身手时，他也在场——哦，我没想到红男爵，是的。所以红男爵正在成为空中伟大的王牌飞行员，并基本上使德国空军赢得了战场制空权。因此，那种空中弥漫着危险的感觉——这同样也是贯穿托尔金小说的主题，那种危险潜伏在那里的感觉——而且在不久之后，将不再是飞机，而是翼手龙身上的巫王，但这就是它的样子。不过很显然，这种恐怖感的灵感不仅仅来自中世纪文学，它显然来自于他在战壕中的经历。
for those who haven't read the books or seen the films, but he has to get rid of the ring and thereby destroy evil by dropping it in the crack of a volcano. Very complicated reasons. And Mordor is a land of darkness and horror. And Tolkien said later about this that the war so the first world war made me poignantly aware of the beauty of the world i remember miles and miles of seething tortured earth perhaps best described in the chapter about the approaches to mordor so yeah i think that that sense of the earth being tortured
霍比特人由于某种我们不会深入探讨的复杂原因，必须前往一片名为莫多（Mordor）的土地——对于那些没有读过书或看过电影的人来说，但他必须除掉魔戒，从而通过将其扔进火山裂缝来摧毁邪恶。非常复杂的原因。而莫多是一片黑暗与恐怖的土地。托尔金后来对此事评论说：“这场战争——也就是第一次世界大战，让我痛苦地意识到世界的美丽。我记得无数英里沸腾的、遭受摧毁的大地，这或许在关于通往莫多之路的那一章中得到了最好的描述。”所以，是的，我认为那种大地饱受折磨的感觉——
which had been floating there really ever since you know he moved to birmingham is is enhanced massively of course by the spectacle of what the horrors of war are doing that's right well there's a chapter called the um the dead marshes and uh the heroes fredo and sam they see the the the swamps are full of dead bodies. And obviously, that clearly comes from the experience of somebody who was on the Western Front in 1916, who saw the fields, the puddles, the gullies, the trenches littered with British and German bodies. And actually, Tolkien once said that the real theme of the Lord of the Rings was death. And you can understand why, because if you look at the figures, from his school, King Edward's, 243 boys were killed in the First World War.
自从他搬到伯明翰以来就一直若隐若现的感觉——当然被战争恐怖景象极大地加剧了。没错，有一章叫做“死者沼泽”，英雄弗罗多和山姆看到沼泽里到处都是死尸。很明显，这来自于一个亲历1916年西线战场的人的体验，他看到原野、水坑、沟壑、战壕里到处都是英国和德国士兵的尸体。事实上，托尔金曾说过，《指环王》真正的主题是死亡。你可以理解为什么，因为如果你看看这些数字：从他的学校爱德华国王学校来看，有243名男孩在第一次世界大战中阵亡。
From his Oxford College, Exeter, 141 young men were killed in the First World War. And Tolkien himself could easily have been killed, but he was fortunate. I mean, it seems weird to say it because he contracts a disease which could conceivably have killed him which is called trench fever which he gets from lice doesn't he um so
从他的牛津学院埃克塞特学院来看，有141名年轻人在第一次世界大战中阵亡。托尔金本人也完全可能丧命，但他很幸运。我的意思是，这样说听起来很奇怪，因为他感染了一种很可能夺去他生命的疾病，叫做战壕热，这是他从虱子那里传染的，对吧？
you're bitten by the lice you you get this kind of very severe kind of flu um i know it's not flu before doctors write in to complain but anyway he's invalided out. And basically, his war is kind of over from that point. So he's invalided out in, I think, the autumn of 1916. And then he spends the rest of the time recuperating. So we forgot to mention that he had married Edith. He'd become betrothed to her in 1914 before the war. She had become a Catholic. He'd basically, that was a non-negotiable. She had to become a Catholic. We had a couple of people commenting about that saying you know what kind of you know he obviously hasn't got it has got it in for women because his wife he forced her to become a catholic
你被虱子咬了，然后得了这种非常严重的流感——我知道在医生写信来抱怨之前这不是流感——总之他因病退役了。基本上，从那时起他的战争就算结束了。所以他在1916年秋天左右因病退役。然后他花了一段剩余的时间在疗养。所以我们忘了提他已经结婚了。他在1914年战争爆发前就与伊迪丝订婚了。她已经改信天主教了。他基本上——那是不可妥协的，她必须成为天主教徒。我们有几个人对此发表评论说，你知道，他显然对女性有成见，因为他强迫他的妻子成为天主教徒。
i mean it's a sign i think of his intense piety that he takes it so seriously and she's so devoted to him that she will risk the you know the displeasure of her family by doing it and so she she had she'd married him just before he goes and she then she she follows him around she's pregnant then has a child then gets pregnant again so really tough for her as he's moved from hospital to hospital and then post to post and every time he seems to be recovering he relapses again and there is a key moment where he gets um he's at a place called roost which is just south of the humber and there's a wood and he goes with edith into this wood and it's spring and it's spectacularly beautiful and he's lying you know he still haunted by the prospect i think this is 1917 so still haunted by the prospect that he he will probably have to go back to the front, but it is breathtakingly beautiful. It's English spring.
我的意思是，我认为这标志着他强烈的虔诚，他对此如此认真，而她对他是如此忠诚，以至于她宁愿冒着惹恼家人的风险也要这么做。所以她在他在他参军前不久嫁给了他，然后她一直跟随他四处奔波，当时她怀孕了，然后生了一个孩子，接着又怀孕了——随着他从一家医院转到另一家医院，从一个驻地转到另一个驻地，这对她来说真的非常艰难。而且每次他似乎在康复时，他又会复发。有一个关键时刻，他来到了一个叫罗斯特（Roost）的地方，就在亨伯河以南，那里有一片树林，他和伊迪丝一起走进了这片树林，当时正值春天，景色美得惊人，而他躺在那里——我认为这是1917年，他仍然被这样一种前景所困扰：他可能不得不重返前线，但这里美得令人窒息。那是英格兰的春天。
It's everything that he would dream of. And Edith dances for him and he clings to the memory of this and he constructs a story about a mortal Beren and an elf, an elvish princess, and elves are immortal. And it's about the love between the mortal and the immortal. And in due course, the immortal abandons her immortality, and they marry and have a kind of short life together. And this is a story that Tolkien writes again and again and again over the course of his life. And when in due course they die on the tombstone that Dominic prevented me from seeing, Tolkien describes himself as Beren and Edith as Luthien. And it's obviously the story that more than any other is the wellspring of his his emotional life and it's it's framed in in you know these ancient languages these ancient epics but it's clearly also massively bred of
这是他梦寐以求的一切。伊迪丝为他翩翩起舞，他紧紧抓住这段记忆不放，并构思了一个故事：一个凡人贝伦（Beren）和一位精灵，一位精灵公主——精灵是长生不老的。这个故事讲述了凡人与永生者之间的爱情。最终，永生者放弃了她的永生，他们结为连理，共同度过了一段短暂的生命。这就是托尔金在自己的一生中一遍又一遍、反反复复书写的故事。当他们最终离世时，在多米尼克阻止我看到的墓碑上，托尔金将自己描述为贝伦，将伊迪丝描述为露西恩（Luthien）。这显然是比任何其他故事都更能成为他情感生活源泉的故事，它被包裹在这些古老的语言、古老的史诗之中，但显然它也极大地孕育自
the war and tolkien as the person who is who probably will die i mean it's it's it's it's so painful yeah it's the kind of thing people would imagine people sniggering at or sneering at. But actually, it's very moving when you read the way he writes about it and the fact that it's chiseled on their tombstones and so on. It obviously means an enormous amount, you would assume, to him, but also to her. I would say it's the emotional heart. I mean, because it's also something that then reappears in Lord of the Rings with Aragorn. Well, people tell the story, don't they? They're conscious of it as a story.
战争，以及托尔金作为那个可能随时会死的人——我的意思是，这太痛苦了。是的，这是那种人们会想象遭到耻笑或嘲弄的事情。但事实上，当你读到他关于此事的文字以及它被刻在他们的墓碑上等等时，是非常感人的。你可以猜想，这对他、对她显然都意味着极其重大的意义。我要说这是情感的核心。我的意思是，因为这也是后来在《指环王》中与阿拉贡一起重现的情节。好吧，人们讲述这个故事，不是吗？他们意识到这是一个故事。
So Arwen also is an elf who's immortal and Aragorn's immortal. So it's obviously this idea of a man who is doomed to die in love with someone who will be immortal is absolutely the heart. Anyway, Tolkien doesn't die. No, he doesn't but it's about this point tom that he starts he's he's scribbling away at his stories not the stories that most people now associate with tolkien the hobbit and the lord of the rings but he's he's creating this whole um world of legend these myths and folk tales and so on, that he's scribbling, as he says himself, in huts full of blasphemy and smut. So in other words, in these sort of jerry-built huts where soldiers are recuperating, he is scribbling on some piece of paper the sort of stories that he
所以阿尔温也是一个长生不老的精灵，而阿拉贡是凡人。所以这种注定要死的人与一个将永生的人相爱的主意，绝对是核心所在。无论如何，托尔金没有死。不，他没有死，但正是在这个时候，汤姆，他开始——他在他的故事上涂涂改改，不是那些现在人们最常与托尔金联系在一起的故事——《霍比特人》和《指环王》，而是他正在创造整个——这个传说世界，这些神话和民间故事等等，他在——正如他自己所说的那样，在充满亵渎和下流话的小屋里涂鸦。换句话说，在这些士兵疗养的简陋棚屋里，他在一些纸片上涂抹着那些他
was thinking about before the war, except that now they are so, they are doom laden and there's this sort of the preoccupation with death and with immortality and with sort of cities that are doomed. So the first story he writes, The Fall of Gondolin, 1917, which you can now buy, which is posthumously published. That's about a city that is attacked by these kind of great sort of mechanical dragons and falls inevitably. And there's this sort of pessimism and sort of despair at the heart of the story. And you can absolutely, this is a response to the First World War. You wouldn't have got it without William Morris and the high Victorians and the sort of medievalism of that period. But you also wouldn't have got it, I think, without the experience of the trenches and the Western Front.
在战前就一直在思考的故事，只不过现在它们充满了末日悲剧色彩，并且有一种对死亡、对永生以及对那些注定要毁灭的城市的执念。所以他写的第一篇故事《贡多林的陷落》（The Fall of Gondolin，1917年），你现在可以买到，这是在他死后出版的。那是关于一座遭到某种巨大的机械巨龙袭击并不可避免地陷落的城市。这个故事的核心有一种悲观主义和绝望感。你绝对可以看得出，这是对第一次世界大战的回应。如果没有威廉·莫里斯（William Morris）和晚期维多利亚时代的人以及那个时期的中世纪主义，你就不可能会有这个；但我想，如果没有在战壕和西线战场的经历，你同样也不会拥有它。
Yeah, absolutely. And it's the first piece of writing, isn't it, where you can see the horrors of mechanized warfare being recalibrated and kind of given the appearance of dragons and balrogs and all these kind of monsters. Yeah, and it's very powerful. But I think also what's incredibly important for understanding Tolkien's literary direction, but I think also the appeal that he has held, certainly for English readers, is that he is consciously trying to fill what he sees as a gap. So he's been reading in Finnish literature, and he's incredibly impressed by the antiquity of these Finnish tales. And he reads in Norse epic, Icelandic epic.
是的，绝对是。这是第一篇你可以看到机械化战争的恐怖被重新校准、并被赋予巨龙、炎魔以及所有这类怪物外形的文学作品，不是吗？是的，这非常具有震撼力。但我也认为，对于理解托尔金的文学走向——以及我认为他对读者的吸引力（当然是对英国读者而言）极其重要的原因在于，他在有意识地试图填补他所认为的空白。所以他一直在阅读芬兰文学，并且对这些芬兰故事的古老程度印象深刻。他阅读北欧史诗、冰岛史诗。
Again, he's very, very impressed at the way that these ancient stories and legends have survived. And he is terribly upset that England doesn't have anything really comparable, perhaps Beowulf, perhaps a few other poems, but not much else. And he blames the norman conquest for this so he is he is the french who the villains time well he he's he's so he has very kind of very very dogmatic opinion so he's very keen on finnish but hates french he goes to paris and complain you know you talked about the um talking about the officer's mess but he views um paris in a very similar way he complained about the vulgarity and the jabber about the officer's mess but he views um paris in a very similar way he complained about the vulgarity and the jabber and the spitting and the indecency that's what i think
同样地，他对这些古老的故事和传说得以保存的方式留下了非常非常深刻的印象。他极为痛心的是，英国竟然没有什么真正能与之相比的东西，也许《贝奥武夫》算，也许还有其他几首诗，但没有别的了。他把这一切归咎于诺曼征服，所以他——法国人就是坏人，时间到了吗？好吧，他——他的观点非常非常教条，所以他非常喜欢芬兰语，但讨厌法语。他去巴黎旅行并抱怨——你知道的，你刚才提到关于军官食堂的事，但他对巴黎的看法也非常相似，他抱怨那种庸俗、喋喋不休、吐痰和不文明——我认为这非常、非常“桑德布鲁克”（指保守或传统派视角），但他滔滔不绝地痛骂诺曼征服，就像那些对英国脱欧感到愤怒的人痛骂脱欧公投一样。那是巨大的创伤，巨大的恐怖，他对其体验的生动和刻骨铭心，就像今天某人可能会哀叹英国脱欧一样。于是他给自己设定了重建英国本可能拥有的传说和故事的任务。是的，而且必须要说的是，汤姆，他并不是凭空做到的，不，他如此沉浸在语言和语言历史中，以至于他正在拾取这些微小的碎片，不是吗？这就是我们刚才读到的那个“埃伦德尔”的来源——对托尔金来说，是语言先于一切，然后他必须决定，这些词是什么意思？这些名字是什么意思？它们是从哪里来的？这成为了他伟大的使命。而他的感觉是，不仅仅是英国失去了神话，而且英国——我想在某种程度上，
very very soundbrooke but he goes on about the normal conquest in the way that that that people who are upset about britain leaving the eu go on about the brexit vote it's the great trauma it's the great horror and he experiences as vividly and viscerally as someone today might kind of lament Brexit. And so he sets himself the task of reconstructing the legends and the stories that England might have had yes and it's important to say tom he doesn't do this from nowhere no he's so immersed in the languages and the history of language that he's picking up these tiny fragments isn't he and and so that's where the um the aurendal the one that we we read just before comes from that that for tolkien it's the language that comes first and then he has to decide you know what do these words mean what do these names mean where are they these names mean? Where are they coming from? And that becomes his great mission. And his feeling is that it's not just that England has lost its mythology, but it's also that England is, and I think to a degree
可能大多数人会觉得荒谬，但托尔金坚信这一点并且感受如此强烈，以至于他确实实现了他着手去做的事情——这太惊人了——创造了这个神话。但他觉得英国对于那些萦绕在北方神话中的人们来说是神圣的。这种想法认为，曾有一群人生活在这些土地上，他们某种程度上高于凡人，他最初给他们起名为“诺姆人”（gnomes）。是的，不幸的是。你知道吗，花园小矮人（garden gnome），汤姆，直到20世纪30年代晚期才被发明出来。
that probably most people would find risible, except that Tolkien believes and feels it so strongly that he has indeed achieved what he set out to do, which is astonishing, and create this mythology. But he feels that England was sacred to a kind of people who haunt the mythologies of the North. This idea that there was a people who lived in these lands that were somehow higher than mortal humans, to whom originally he gives the name of gnomes. Yes, unfortunately. Do you know the garden gnome, Tom, was not invented until the late 1930s.
所以当托尔金最初称他们为“诺姆人”时，那并不是一个荒谬的、某种……不，但它确实显得非常搞笑。我的意思是，现在他称他们为“诺姆人”完全是荒谬的，但这只是因为我们想到了维克托·梅尔德鲁（Victor Meldrew）在《一个活生生的人》（One Foot in the Grave）里订购了290个花园小矮人或者类似的事情，但是，呃——他们基本上就是精灵，不是吗？他们就是——他们有点像——精灵身上有一种天使的成分，你觉得呢，对托尔金来说？所以在中世纪文学、
So when Tolkien first calls them the gnomes, that's not a ludicrous and sort of... No, but it does seem very funny. I mean, now it's completely ludicrous that he calls them the gnomes but that's only because we think of victor meldrew ordering 290 garden gnomes or whatever it was in one foot in the grave but um uh they they are basically elves aren't they there they are they're they're kind of a bit like there's an element of the angel about the elves don't you think with for talking uh so in the in the medieval literature in the
北欧文学中，精灵是更加矛盾的角色，他们相当危险，相当阴暗。所以我们录制了一集关于北欧巫术、维京巫术的节目即将播出，而精灵正是这个奇异世界的一部分，其中还包括矮人——他们生活在维京世界中人类极限之外的地方。所以精灵显然源自于此。而托尔金对精灵、仙子以及所有这类东西在英国所扮演的角色的厌恶在于，它们被美化了，被贬低了。它们成了儿童角色，不是吗？
norse literature elves are much more ambivalent figures they're quite dangerous quite dark dark so we've recorded an episode um about norse sorcery viking sorcery that will be going out and elves are kind of part of this this strange world that include dwarves as well um that that lived beyond the limits of the human in in Viking world. So elves are clearly coming from that. And what Tolkien hates about the role that elves and fairies and all that kind of stuff plays in England is that they've been prettified and kind of diminished. They're kids figures, aren't they?
它们是儿童角色，就像亚瑟·柯南·道尔那样，你知道的，女孩子们，花园里的仙子。他不喜欢的，他讨厌那个。所以他想要重振这一点。他逐渐觉得，基本上英国就是精灵的伟大故乡。我知道我能听到那些讨厌托尔金的人对此发出嘲笑。但我认为他带着这种从战争中走出来的想法，而且我认为这对他来说至关重要。他对此感受有多深的衡量标准，正是这个世界最终承载的情感分量，
They're kids figures, the kind of thing that Arthur Conan Doyle, you know, the girls, the fairies in the garden. He doesn't like, he hates that. And so he wants to kind of revive that. And he comes to feel basically that England was the great home of the elves. And I know I can hear people who hate Tolkien kind of laughing at this. But I think he's coming to this idea of coming out of the war, and I think it matters terribly to him. And that the measure of how deeply he feels it is precisely the kind of emotional heft that this world comes to carry,
不仅对托尔金如此，对千百万人也是如此，而且不仅仅是住在英国的人，还包括全世界。这种关于神话的执念，对神话、传奇、民间故事的痴迷，不仅仅是晚期维多利亚时代的遗产，而且你在两次世界大战之间的文化中到处都能看到它。所以，我的意思是，把托尔金——对某些听众来说，把托尔金和这些作家放在一起似乎近乎亵渎。但让我们想想爱尔兰的威廉·巴特勒·叶芝（William Butler Yeats），
not just for Tolkien, but for millions of people, and not just living in England either across the world. This thing about myth and the obsession with myth, with legend, with kind of folk tales, it's not just a legacy of the kind of late Victorian period, but also you see it all everywhere in the interwar culture. So, I mean, it seems odd to put Tolkien, and to some listeners it would seem almost blasphemous to put Tolkien with these writers. But let's think about William Butler Yeats in Ireland,
或者詹姆斯·乔伊斯（James Joyce），你知道的，他着迷于神话、传说以及对其进行加工的新方法；或者T.S.艾略特（T.S. Eliot），另一位作家。你之前提到过艾略特，他作为一个经历过第一次世界大战的人，正在考虑从西方文明破碎的残骸中拾取碎片来尝试创造一些新的东西。我的意思是，托尔金——好吧，他可能看起来远在天边，但我认为其中确实存在明确的对应关系。即使你讨厌托尔金，他在某种程度上也明显属于相同的社会圈子。所以也许当我们审视第二次世界大战的经历时，稍后再谈艾略特，因为我认为那里有非常有趣且或许显而易见的平行之处。不过，就
or indeed James Joyce, taking, you know, who's fascinated by myths and legends and new ways of working on them, or T.S. Eliot, another writer. You mentioned Eliot before, somebody who coming out of the First World War is thinking about picking up fragments from the shattered remains of Western civilization to try to make something new. I mean, Tolkien is, okay, he might seem a million miles away, but I think there are definite kind of correspondences there. And even if you hate Tolkien, he's clearly part of the same milieu in a way. So maybe come to Eliot later when we look at the experience of the Second World War, because I think there are really interesting and perhaps overt parallels there but just on the on the topic of
乔伊斯而言——你会说《尤利西斯》是一部你能想象到的与《指环王》截然不同的宏大小说，除了乔伊斯和托尔金都在他们难以置信的不同方式中，对语言着迷。所以在战争结束时，托尔金得到了一份在词典工作的工作。所以他成了一名词典编纂者。他负责W字母，不是吗？《牛津英语词典》。他负责WA。所以他负责“权力”（power）和“所有”（one）以及诸如此类的各种词汇。
joyce who you'd say ulysses is as different a novel as you could imagine to lord of the rings except that both of them both joyce and tolkien in their unbelievably different ways are obsessed by language so when tolkien at the end of the war, Tolkien gets a job working on the dictionary. So he becomes a lexicographer. He does W, doesn't he? The Oxford English Dictionary. He does WA. So he does one power and one and all kinds of things like that.
然后他在利兹大学找到了一份工作。接着他在牛津大学找到了一份工作。这就是罗林斯与博斯沃思教授职位（Rawlinson and Bosworth Professorship）。基本上从那个时候起，你知道的，他一直留在牛津大学，汉弗莱·卡彭特（Humphrey Carpenter）在他的传记中说，正是在这个时候，他的生活——你知道的，他的生活基本上不再有趣了，你知道的，他只是过着牛津大学学者的一生，但托尔金无时无刻不在思考语言，并对它着迷。我认为，如果你想比较，
And then he gets a job at Leeds. And then he gets a job at Oxford. And this is the Rawlinson and bosworth professorship and basically from that point on you know he stays at oxford um and humphrey carpenter in his biography says that at this point his his life you know his his life stops being interesting basically you know he just leads the life of an oxford don but all the time tolkien is thinking about language and is obsessed by it. And I think that, so if you wanted to compare,
比方说，《指环王》中的一章和《尤利西斯》中的一章，你是可以做到的。你可以做到。所以在《尤利西斯》中有一章——评论家称之为“独眼巨人”。
say a chapter from Lord of the Rings with a chapter from Ulysses, you could do it. You could do it. So there is a chapter in, in Ulysses that has the, you know, critics call it the Cyclops. It's,
那是利奥波德·布卢姆（Leopold Bloom），《尤利西斯》的英雄，在一家酒吧里遇到了一位爱尔兰民族主义者，然后陷入了——爱尔兰民族主义者向他扔了一个玻璃杯，布卢姆离开了，这基本上就是情节。但整件事情是通过——各种形式的英语来表达的，从最早的古英语形式一直延续到现在。乔伊斯对英语作为一种语言演变的方式着迷，他在整章中都在玩弄这一点。在《指环王》中，托尔金有这样一章，叫做“埃尔隆德会议”，来自中土世界不同地区的各族人民齐聚一堂。同样地，你可以准确地通过他们使用的
it's Leopold Bloom, the hero of ulysses meets with an irish nationalist in a pub and kind of gets into the irish nationalist throws a glass at him and bloom leaves and that's basically the plot but the whole thing is couched through um various forms of english starting from the earliest form of old english and going right the way up to the present day joyce is fascinated by the way in which English as a language evolves, and he makes play with this throughout the chapter. In Lord of the Rings, Tolkien has this chapter called the Council of Elrond, where various peoples from different parts of Middle Earth come and meet. And again, you can exactly gauge how ancient are people they are by the kind of
英语来衡量他们的人是多么古老。所以代表20世纪20年代英国的霍比特人使用的是当代形式的英语；但随后你有了人类、矮人、精灵，他们都来自历史的不同时期，并且都拥有微妙不同的英语形式、微妙不同的词汇。我认为这种平行或许是一个引人入胜的平行，乔伊斯和托尔金以他们非常、非常不同的方式，都在利用语言来表达关于事物不稳定性的一些非常重要的真理。因为如果语言在不断演变，那就意味着人们会被时代抛在身后。这很有趣，不是吗？但我想区别在于，乔伊斯在20世纪20年代就已经名声大噪了。我的意思是，这并不是区别，这是一种区别，而托尔金则完全默默无闻。所以他为自己的语言和
english they use so the hobbits who are representatives of 1920s england speak in a contemporary form of english but then you have men you have dwarves you have elves they all come from different periods of history and they all have subtly different forms of English, subtly different forms of vocabulary. And I think that the parallel is perhaps, I think an intriguing one, the way in which both Joyce and Tolkien in their very, very different ways are using language to express quite important truths, I think, about the instability of things. Because if language is constantly evolving, then it means that people can be left behind. That's interesting, isn't it? But I think the difference is that Joyce is well known in the 1920s. I mean, this is not the difference, it's a difference. And Tolkien is completely and utterly obscure. So all the work he's doing on his languages and
他那些想象中的世界所做的所有工作，有点像阁楼里一套火车模型。我的意思是，他做这件事——当他回到家时，你可以想象伊迪丝说“我们今晚做什么？”而他说“哦，我又在写关于诺姆人的事了”。这是一种非常阳春白雪的战争重演，不是吗？有点像穿着内战时期的军服什么的，而他极其严肃地对待它。他在1926年结识了一位新朋友，叫C.S.刘易斯（C.S. Lewis），他是一个志同道合的人，因为他在第一次世界大战中失去了除了一个之外的所有朋友，对吧？刘易斯曾说过，到1918年，我失去了除了一个之外所有的挚友。没错，所以他只剩下一个朋友，而且他其实并不怎么常见到对方，或者说和对方相处得不是很融洽，因为对方是个卫理公会学校的校长，不是吗？他成了一名校长，没错，在萨默塞特或者类似的地方，我想。
his sort of imagined worlds and things, it's a bit like the equivalent of a train set in an attic. I mean, he does it he does it when he comes home you can imagine edith saying what are we doing tonight and he says well i'm writing about the gnomes again you know it's very highbrow kind of battle reenacting isn't it it's kind of dressing up in the civil war uniform or something and he takes it tremendously seriously um he has a new friend who he meets in i think 1926 called c.s lewis who is a like-minded because he's lost all but one of his friends yeah in the first world war line doesn't he that by 1918 i had lost all but one of my closest friends exactly so he's got one left and he doesn't actually see
所以托尔金当时在牛津，他遇到了这个身材高大、热情洋溢的阿尔斯特人，名叫C.S.刘易斯。刘易斯显然上过一所非常好的学校，汤姆，正如你所知，绝对是顶级学校，就像最优秀的播客那样。刘易斯也对语言感兴趣，对北欧神话感兴趣，对盎格鲁-撒克逊人以及所有这类东西感兴趣。他们去酒吧，朗读彼此的作品，过得非常愉快。但托尔金——没有任何理由认为他会——除了他的学术工作和对《贝奥武夫》及这类东西的兴趣之外，没有任何理由认为他会成为任何形式的公众人物。然后著名的故事是，基本上，因为他薪水不高而且手头拮据，他在夏天批改学校证书考试的试卷。这个故事说的是，
him very much or get on with him very well anymore because he's a methodist headmaster isn't he he becomes a headmaster exactly in somerset or something like that i think um so so tolkien's there in oxford he meets this big ebullient ulsterman called cs lewis who obviously went to a very good school tom as you will as you all know top absolutely top school um like the very best podcasters and um lewis is is interested in language too and he's interested in Norse myths, and he's interested in Anglo-Saxons and all of that kind of stuff. And they go to the pub and they read each other's stuff and they have a tremendous time. But Tolkien, there's no reason to think he's ever going to be, apart from his academic work and his interest in Beowulf and
大约在1930年的一天。他完全无聊透顶。你可以想象那个场景，你知道的，下午过半，又是一份试卷，而有一页是空白的。你可以想象那个场景，你知道的，下午过半，又是一份试卷，其中一份试卷上有一页空白，他在上面涂鸦道：“在地下的一个洞里住着一个霍比特人。”然后他不知道该拿它怎么办。
these kinds of things, there's no reason to think that he's ever going to be a public figure of any kind. And then the famous story is that basically, cause he's not very well paid and he's hard up, he's marking, you know, school certificate exam papers in the summer. And the story goes,
他知道这是一个故事的开端，但他不知道是什么。哇，多么精彩的笔记，多么精彩的笔记，多米尼克。“其余就是历史了，其余的——好吧，其余的确实是历史了，托尔金剧集第二篇，我想是的。”我们不应该把这当做告别语，虽然我们其实应该这么做。所以我想我们应该在今天的节目下划上一条线，然后在我们的下一期节目中回来——看看《霍比特人》，看看《指环王》，看看精灵。我们有他们，
it's about 1930 one day. He's completely bored. You can imagine the scene, you know, mid afternoon, another paper, and he, there's a blank. You can imagine the scene, you know, mid-afternoon, another paper, and there's a blank page in one of the scripts, and he scribbles in a hole in the ground there lived a hobbit. And then he doesn't know what to do with it.
我们有精灵——“怎么又是他妈的精灵”，C.S.刘易斯当时没这么说，对吧？不，那肯定得被消音，那——
He knows it's the beginning of a story, but he doesn't know what. Well, what a note. What a note, Dominic. The rest is is history the rest well the rest is is history talking episode part two i think yes we don't do that as a sign off as much as we should you know so i think we should draw a line there under today's episode and then come back uh in our next episode look at the hobbit look at the Lord of the Rings look at elves we've got them
我简直不敢相信你，我简直不敢相信你竟然提到了这个，哦，太不尊重了。无论如何，这是一个杜撰的故事，所以我们下次再见。
elves we've got them not another f***ing elf which C.S. Lewis didn't say did he no and that will have to be that will have to be bleeped that will
向着莫多，向着莫多，拜拜。无论如何，所以我们下次再见，还有……向着莫多，向着莫多，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的其余》。想要收听独家番外、提前解锁节目、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
I can't believe you I can't believe you went there oh so disrespectful that's the apocryphal story anyway so we will we'll see you next time and
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。在这里，你可以每周获取娱乐新闻、精彩评论以及一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们会带你一探娱乐业幕后，揭秘这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、
to Mordor to Mordor bye bye Anyway, so we will see you next time. And... Temodo. Temodo. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
独家番外节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、
bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
独家加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。